Four members of the radical group the flag
smashers were killed today in a car bomb
attack as they were being transferred to a
high security prison there were no suspects
in the bombing hey walker check your phone looks
like our friend zemo kind of got the last laugh
couldn't have worked better if i
planned it myself oh well maybe i did
yeah well yeah things are about to get
weird we're not gonna need a captain america
we're gonna need a us agent that's great keep
your phone man back back and back back back
the carter name has always been synonymous
with service trust and we'd like to offer
you a full pardon there may be an opening in
your old division welcome home agent carter
start lining up our buyers super
soldiers might be off the menu but
we're about to have full access to government
secrets prototype weapons you name it
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
falcon and winter soldier episode 6 finale
post credit scene video also got some news about a
big captain america movie that they just announced
captain america 4 is actually happening now with
falcon's version of captain america obviously
the post credit scenes are meant to tease what's
happening next in the marvel series in the marvel
movies so we'll break it all down there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs here and the producers people
like kevin feige have been clarifying what's
actually going on behind the scenes so i'll add
that to the video as well but if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the marvel
disney plus episodes i'll be doing videos for all
the marvel series that are happening this year
also the marvel movies as well loki is going
to be the next big series to premiere in a
little while so be sure to subscribe to get those
careful for spoilers for everything that happened
during falcon and winter soldier obviously if
you haven't seen the episodes yet i'm assuming
most of you have by now but it all starts with
baron zemo on the raft chilling out in his cell
reading russian german literature villainous man
of culture listening and smiling hearing that his
contingency plan to get rid of the flag smasher
super soldiers was successful everyone pressed f
in the chat to pay respects to the flag smashers
zemo's kind of like an evil version of batman in
the mcu now so it would make sense that he has
an evil version of alfred as well but obviously
he's sitting there in the raft indefinitely and
that's basically where thunderbolt ross's home
base is now where they would find other characters
that are suitable for future thunderbolts and dark
avengers stuff so in addition to teasing the
future of zemo they're also sort of crossing
this over with what's happening in the other
different post credit scenes as well also
thank you very much to the people who are able to
translate russian and german titles because the
books that he's reading there they're not meant
to be really huge teasers or major easter eggs
or anything like that like this book is alexander
pushkin he was one of russia's most famous poets
who wrote a bunch of books during the romantic era
of literature that served as commentary for events
that were going on in real world russia history
at the time there were a lot of peasant revolts a
lot of rich people meeting untimely circumstances
lots of tragedy lots of love stories so you could
look at him reading those books as a metaphor for
the events of his life in recent history with the
flag smasher uprising but this other book is from
alexander von humboldt who was one of the founders
of modern geographical sciences who also just
happened to have an even more famous scientist
brother called wilhelm von humboldt who was a
scientist serving the king of prussia at the time
this book is just called views of nature one of
the books that he wrote so zemo is just a man
of culture just enjoying his time in captivity
until obviously somebody comes along to recruit
him for thunderbolt stuff but it's not like the
books themselves have special titles that they're
going to use for the captain america 4 movie
armor wars the thunderbolts or avengers 5. and
obviously really big news we should say captain
america 4 was announced right after they dropped
the finale on friday in fact they announced it
right after i posted my finale video so i wish
they would have announced it just a couple hours
earlier i would have included it in that video
but they are doing a falcon captain america movie
the show runner from falcon winter soldier malcolm
spellman is coming back to develop it but they
just announced that it was in development so
it'll be at least two years bare minimum before we
see that movie maybe even three years depending on
how fast they figure the story out as well as
lock down which other big avengers characters
they want to use during that like the last captain
america movie they did was civil war so how do you
do an even bigger captain america movie with
a new version of captain america than that
there's probably going to be a whole bunch of big
avengers level stuff happening in it i'll do more
videos about that when we get more information
but it should go without saying that in addition
to the post-credit scenes the stuff that they're
teasing all the ending scenes for the characters
in the falcon and winter soldier finale i think
that all the major characters that survive like
winter soldier zemo val madame hydra whatever you
want to call her julia louis-dreyfus character
john walker us agent sharon carter power broker
all of them will be coming back in captain america
four but some of them will come back sooner
than that in other marvel disney plus series
so while normally i would be talking about them
setting stuff up in the falcon and winter soldier
finale for season two because kevin feige
anthony mackie sebastian sand have all been
talking about doing a season two now i think the
captain america four movie will effectively be
the story of what season two would have been had
they not done the movie then if they actually
do a legit season two after that they'll just
call it captain america and the winter soldier
instead of calling it falcon and winter
soldier season two so if they do season two
probably not going to be for like another three
maybe even four years but that's also what the
post-credits scene title card is for the special
title captain america and the winter soldier
some of you in the comments on my finale video
were also confused because you said you saw a
title card that said captain america and the white
wolf will return like the title cards that they
put at the end of some marvel movies saying
so and so character will return like at the
end of avengers infinity war it said thanos will
return which was a reference to avengers end game
well if you did see a white wolf title card then
the chances are you are probably watching a fan
edited video and they just added that to the
video there were a lot of those just because the
marvel stuff is so popular the credits from the
actual episode don't have any kind of white wolf
will return type of statement in the credits
it's only the wakandans that call him that
the whole john walker scene obviously is there
to explain what's happening with him next in
the mcu becoming the us agent character from the
comics most of us like early on in my videos for
the series before the episodes drop when we were
just getting the trailers i was actually already
referring to him as us agent just because that's
what i think of him when i think of john walker
but clearly they were trying to evolve him into
that version of the character through the series
that's what the joke about the black costume
is like it's the same thing only black because
his us agent costume in the comics is black he
still uses a captain america shield it just has
us in the middle instead of the captain america
star and he's not really evil he's just more of
an anti-hero and that's basically what they're
implying here he's going to be doing some shady
stuff for val but he is still on the government's
payroll like he's not being locked up in prison or
anything like that that was the whole idea with
him trying to redeem himself during the finale
when it comes to the val character though
the showrunner said that they created her
on the show to be a darker version of nick fury
implying that they have much bigger plans for her
in the future because why would you create a new
nick fury character and then only use them once so
i think her talking about all this stuff setting
this big team up in the background is mostly
a teaser for thunderbolts potentially also dark
avengers related stuff that they'll probably weave
into the future mcu projects in the next five
years between the movies like captain america four
and the marvel disney plus series like she says
things are about to get very weird and they're
going to need a quote-unquote us agent they won't
need captain america because things are going to
get really shady she'll be running all these black
ops in the background with morally questionable
anti-hero characters slowly assembling her roster
that would eventually become the thunderbolts
and because nick fury is this character that has
ties to everything that happens in the mcu through
the infinity saga and obviously he's still alive
so he's still connected to all this stuff in the
background val being a darker nick fury will also
probably have ties to all the major players in
the mcu like thunderbolt ross potentially future
big mcu villains that they have yet to introduce
and what they'll probably wind up doing is leaving
the bigger a-list dark avengers related stuff just
for the movies to handle like the biggest of the
big stuff like thunderbolt ross turning into red
hulk we've all kind of been thinking about that in
the background expecting it to happen eventually
that would probably be a big twist that they would
leave for the movie maybe even captain america 4
hopefully we'll see some easter eggs during that
like what's bigger than captain america civil war
well they could do some big dark avengers stuff
in captain america 4 that would be pretty cool
all the thunderbolt stuff that they'll probably
wind up doing in the future is probably going
to be a marvel disney plus series with other
villain characters that they don't use in dark
avengers like baron zemo will probably wind up
leading a version of the thunderbolts the way
he did in the comics but because he's such a big
character and he's like a dark version of batman
in the mcu i am expecting him to come back at some
point during captain america 4. but getting to the
sharon carter of it all because that big sharon
carter post-credit scene twist is what most of
the conversation is about after the finale truly
revealing that she is the power broker and will
continue to act as the power broker despite
infiltrating the us government the cia a lot
of people now taking a look back at what they
actually told us about her character during the
series because when you do look at the facts that
they gave us just on paper a lot of what she's
doing and what she's said about her actions don't
totally make sense and there are some continuity
errors which is why i think so many people are
asking if she's secretly a scroll pretending to
be sharon carter like that would be an easy way
for this to all make sense so i will address the
scroll theory we do have a secret invasion series
that they're doing with nick fury next year in
the scrolls so there are a lot of scrolls in the
mcu right now in positions of power that they're
going to reveal pretty shortly they even just
announced that emilia clarke daenerys targaryen
herself from game of thrones joined the series in
a major role but they didn't say who she's playing
maybe she'll wind up being the scroll empress
that would be a pretty cool twist but the way
the producers in emily van camp have been talking
about the sharon carter power broker twist is that
they wanted to take advantage of the fact that her
character was kind of pushed to the side in the
movies metaphorically and literally like she was
a small player a small bit part in the goings-on
of the avengers and then they didn't really feel
like bringing her back for avengers end game like
they just didn't have room for her character so
the falcon and winter soldier writers were like
hey let's make this a bigger thing in the whole
storyline of her feeling like she was betrayed by
the government when they pardoned everyone from
civil war but her and zemo and zemo was kind of
like the worst defender they said that they wanted
to make her character way more complex like a
more complex spin on her than the simplistic
take that the previous movies had given us
so the way the writer said that they justify this
was that she felt betrayed by her government and
that caused her to have this radical mental shift
where she decided the best way to change the world
to try and take some agency for herself so that
people couldn't do that to her again was to
operate as the power broker who's basically like
a glorified black market dealer in weapons and
technology so they wanted to turn her into more
of a zemo type character or someone like julia
louis-dreyfus character who aren't really good
characters but not really evil characters either
just doing things in their own best interest so
in the post-credits scene when she walks away
from that pardon and calls up her associate and
talks about stealing all this government weapons
technology prototypes to the highest bidder that's
just meant to be one of her random underlings as
the power broker but it's them trying to give her
this metaphorical boss level power upgrade before
new marvel series and movies so that she can more
easily stand her ground against characters like
thunderbolt ross the avengers characters the same
way the zemo or val don't actually have special
powers but they wield a lot of metaphorical
power so people aren't able to push them around
so first thing they make it seem on the series
like sharon carter did not get snapped and she
spent all this time in the five year time jump
becoming the power broker developing her power
base and using these flag smasher characters as
her muscle but here's the thing that a lot of you
spotted she is shown in the avengers endgame
footage when they're watching that powerpoint
presentation on all the major characters who got
snapped at the beginning of the movie you do see
sharon carter's picture here in the background
falcon and winter soldier is meant to take place
a couple months after the events of avengers
end game so a lot of people were like why is she
talking to carly about taking her in on madrapur
under her wing after the snap during this five
year time jump if she herself had been snapped she
wouldn't have been around then this is basically
where the scroll theory came from like maybe this
version of sharon carter is a scroll and that's
why it doesn't make sense but here's the thing
with that a lot of people aren't considering the
spider-man homecoming explainer remember the big
timeline error that they made at the beginning of
spider-man homecoming it said eight years after
the battle of new york when really it had only
been five years because the battle of new york
took place in 2012 and spider-man homecoming takes
place during 2017. kevin feige and the director
john watts admitted that they kind of made an
error and it didn't totally make sense and said
that's kind of why they tried to avoid using very
specific dates in the films so they make errors
like this all the time it's just that people don't
always notice them remember jeans guy from the
mandalorian season two that was another type of
error different error but an error nonetheless
there were even a couple points during falcon and
winter soldier episodes where a lot of you were
like hey there's a guy standing behind this pylon
here in jeans is this just like an extra that they
forgot to edit out of this scene so they even had
jeans guy errors during the falcon and winter
soldier episodes as well usually what happens
with editing errors is that they fix it stealth
and just don't tell anyone so that when you go
back and you try to watch the episode you don't
see the error anymore so i think the whole idea
with sharon carter is that they wanted to do a
much cooler version of her character and obviously
it just kind of broke the timeline a little bit
and they probably just will not address it in
future movies they'll just pretend like it wasn't
a thing so i don't think that she's a scroll i
think that she'll just wind up being a black
market dealer that'll be involved with future
thunderbolt stuff maybe even potentially the armor
war series that's happening next year like she'd
be somebody who would help supply people like
justin hammer or other people that are trying
to repurpose iron man's armor because that's
basically where the armor war series comes from
villains getting their hands on iron man's
technology and then using it in the worst
possible way so hopefully that explains what's
going on with sharon carter like i said though i
do not think that she's a scroll i think it's more
of a spider-man homecoming error type of situation
the only other big thing during the post-credits
scene the big change to the credits was they added
falcon in his captain america suit like there were
tiny little additions that they made to the credit
scene in each of the episodes when new information
was revealed but if there are any other big easter
eggs that you spotted in the ending scenes or the
post-credits scenes that i didn't mention in the
video just write them below in the comments and i
will start doing more loki videos really soon too
we'll get some more trailers for loki pretty soon
while you wait for everything click here for my
full falcon winter soldier episode 6 finale
video and click here for my brand new shang
chi trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!